bonjour a bienvenue surf 42
today's video is sponsored by babel the
number one language learning gap
in the world in 79 a.d the volcano known
as mount vesuvius erupted
in what is probably the single most
famous volcanic event
in human history at the peak of the
eruption which lasted for a full two
days the volcano coughed up a lethal mix
of molten rock pulverized pumice and red
hot ash at a rate of 1.5 million tons
per second
to put the magnitude of the eruption
into human terms the total thermal
energy released was roughly
100 000 times greater than that produced
by the hiroshima and nagasaki nuclear
bombs
it isn't surprising then that those
living in the vicinity
fared rather badly in the aftermath as
the eruption progressed
pyroclastic surges which are basically
fast-moving clouds of rock fragments ash
and noxious gases
tore through the nearby towns of pompeii
and herculaneum
with the force of an industrial
sandblaster the settlements along with
everyone
unlucky enough to have been home at the
time disappeared
under six metres of hot ash
pompei and herculaneum were buried so
completely and so quickly
they created a kind of time capsule
perfectly preserving
a moment in roman history whenever i get
time away
i love traveling in france it's such a
beautiful
country but i always get frustrated and
feel embarrassed by my total inability
to communicate with the locals and
people in shops and cafes
so i'm using babel to learn to speak
french
babel is way better than other language
learning apps i've used
for a start babel has no ads which makes
it a joy to use
unlike other apps that use algorithms to
generate lessons
babble lessons are created by real
people who have vast experience with
teaching languages
and you know what the results speak for
themselves
university studies have shown that just
15 hours of babble
is equal to a semester of college
spanish and that doesn't surprise me
because after just a couple of hours
using babel
i've learned and can recall a long list
of french phrases
that are actually useful in conversation
because babel prepares you for
situations
you will actually encounter in real life
what language have you always wanted to
learn
well you should start today by heading
to my link below
to get fifty percent of six months for a
limited time only
archaeological work began at the sites
in the 18th century
and alongside all the mosaics pottery
and coins the scientists were perplexed
to find
thousands of cavities filled with human
bones
it soon became clear that these strange
voids were created
when the human bodies they contained
rotted away
by pouring plaster inside archaeologists
were able to create
near-perfect outlines of the victims who
had died in the eruption
almost 2 000 years earlier
the growing number of plaster molds
revealed that many of the victims had
died in
twisted agonised positions as a result
it was long assumed the poor old
pompeians had perished from
asphyxiation choked to death on ash
and poisonous gases but recent evidence
suggests they were actually killed
by the extreme temperatures that
accompanied the pyroclastic surges
as high as 300 degrees celsius
the heat was so intense that the organs
and blood of the victims
would have been vaporized killing them
instantly
the brain of one victim was even found
to have been vitrified
turned to glass by the intense heat
those eerie death poses of the pompe
victims were actually caused by heat
shock
contorting the bodies in all it's fought
that 16 000 people were killed
the explosiveness of volcanic eruptions
is measured on a scale known as the
volcanic explosivity index
which runs from zero to eight as utterly
devastating and deadly as the famous
eruption of man vesuvius was it only
came in
at a five on the vei scale for reference
eruptions of this magnitude occur once
every 15 years or
so worldwide to see what happens during
a magnitude 6 eruption
we can fast forward just over 1800 years
after
mount vesuvius sent real estate prices
in pompei and herculaneum through the
floor
literally to 1883. when the indonesian
volcano
krakatoa was readying itself for one of
the most devastating eruptions
in modern human history at the time the
island on which the volcano stood had
three peaks
the tallest of which was 800 meters
above sea level but
things were about to change dramatically
because when krakatoa blew on sunday the
26th of august that year
the eruption was so monumental it
literally smashed these mountains out of
existence
obliterating almost the entire island on
which they stood
in the process the sound of the last and
largest explosion to shake
krakatoa that day was so loud it was
heard
four full hours later off the coast of
mauritius
almost 5 000 kilometers away
for comparison a typical handgun shot
can be heard around two kilometers away
to say the eruption of krakatoa was loud
is almost meaningless when the volcano
blew it is fought to have produced
the single loudest sound created on
earth
in recorded history the british ship
norm castle was minding its own business
in the sunder strait
65 kilometers away when the pressure
wave from the explosion hit
even at that distance the sound was loud
enough
to burst the eardrums of the sailors on
board
it's said that anyone unlucky enough to
have been within 15 kilometers of
krakatoa when it blew
was left permanently death if of course
they survived
at all the colossal shock wave from the
eruption swept around the entire globe
for days afterwards circling the planet
four full times but overexcited air
particles weren't the only thing the
locals had to worry about
the incredible violence of the eruption
unleashed a tsunami of truly
biblical proportions the boiling wave of
water was more than 40 meters high when
it hit the town of merak
56 kilometers away where all but two of
the 2000 inhabitants were killed
all told more than 36 000 people died in
the aftermath of the eruption
but as catastrophic as the 1883 eruption
of krakatoa was
we humans have seen worse and oddly
enough the biggest
baddest volcanic eruption in recorded
history happened
just 68 years before krakatoa
blew itself to bits and less than 900
miles away in the very same country
it's fair to say indonesia was having
one hell of a shitty century
despite being far less famous than its
cousin krakatoa the title
of largest and deadliest volcanic event
to have occurred in modern times
was the 1815 eruption of tambora
the only volcanic explosivity index
seven in almost a thousand years
like krakatoa the eruption of tambora
was cataclysmic
according to eyewitnesses the mountain
itself turned into a flowing massive
liquid magma
when the dust well ash had settled
mount hambora stood a full 1500 meters
shorter
than it had days before a combination of
pyroclastic surges
tsunamis and general destruction is
fought to have taken the lives
of at least 71 000 people but shocking
as that is the tambora eruption is most
famous
for what happened afterwards the volcano
spewed forth so much ash
pumice pulverized rock and sulfur
aerosols into the atmosphere that it
prevented a substantial amount of
sunlight
from reaching the earth's surface as a
result
average global temperatures were reduced
by as much as half a degree celsius
in the aftermath of the eruption that
may not sound like all that much
but 1816 is known as the year without a
summer
for a reason it was the coldest recorded
in europe ever and it wasn't just
europeans who suffered
the monsoon season was knocked off
kilter in parts of asia
and temperatures in north america fell
sharply with snow and frost reported
across much of the country in the middle
of june
the cloyingly cold wet conditions caused
massive crop failure
and led to widespread death of cattle
food prices left alarmingly and famine
inevitably followed
the tambora eruption is even thought to
have caused the emergence of a new
strain of cholera
in india as well as widespread typhus
epidemics
taken as a whole it's fought to knock on
effects
might have claimed 1 million lives
on a slightly less horrific note there
were a couple of silver linings to the
monumental tambora ash cloud
oats became so expensive that horses the
standard mode of transport
of the day became something only the
rich could afford which is fought to
have been a key driver
behind the development of the bicycle
invented
just two years later all this shitty
weather also had the effect of keeping
people shut up indoors
bored out of their brains trapped inside
during a holiday in geneva mary shelley
sat down with a group of friends
lord byron amongst them because
apparently all the famous people in the
past knew each other
to tell ghost stories according to mary
herself
it was that very nice that the idea for
her genre-defining novel
frankenstein came suddenly to life
something her famous monster has been
doing on tv screens and in cinemas the
world over
pretty much ever since there's even some
suggestion
that the tambora eruption might have had
a hand in altering the course of
european history
with foul weather caused by the eruption
postulated as a contributing factor
in the defeat of one napoleon bonaparte
at the battle of waterloo
with mud caused by unseasonal rain
blunting the effectiveness
of the legendary french general's
military maneuvers
now pretty much everyone watching this
video will have heard of vesuvius
and most of you are probably well aware
of krakatoa
too but i'd imagine far
fewer of you are familiar with tambora
modern modern-day pompeii
is a unesco world heritage site so that
accounts for vesuvius's fame but
why is krakatoa so much more well-known
than tambora
the eruptions occurred just decades
apart in the very same country after all
and the impact of tambora was undeniably
the greater
of the two the answer to this little
poser
most likely lies in the global
telegraphic network
that was painstakingly built in the time
between the two eruptions
which meant that when krakatoa blew
itself to bits in 1885
it became what's often cited as the
first
truly global news event in history
making headlines
across the world vesuvius
krakatoa and tambora represents some of
the deadliest
most catastrophic volcanic eruptions in
modern human history
but despite its size and impact the
largest of them
tambora only measured in at a mere 7
on the volcanic explosivity index and
i say mere because the vei
is a logarithmic scale meaning
each number represents 10 times the
explosivity index of the level preceding
it
that means roughly speaking the eruption
of krakatoa in 1885
was 10 times larger than the famous
eruption
of vesuvius and the eruption of tambora
in 1815
was 100 times larger a score of 8 is
reserved only for
super volcanoes capable of erupting with
such devastating forces to make vesuvius
look like a cute school science project
cobbled together with paper mache and
dry ice
you've probably heard of the super
volcano that slumbers beneath
yellowstone national park
in wyoming but you may be surprised to
learn that there are plenty more dotted
around the globe
around 20 and all but luckily for us
humans
super volcanic eruptions are extremely
rare
you'll be relieved to hear that only
around 40 vei
8 eruptions are known to have taken
place
in the last 130 million years or so
the most recent was the euro-winner
eruption in new zealand
about 26 500 years ago
as far as super volcanic eruptions go it
was a relative tiddler
but it still belts forth around 1170
cubic
kilometers of ash pumice and magma
that's enough erupted material to cover
the entirety of england in a layer of
deposits
more than a kilometer deep put simply
outside of asteroid strikes super
volcanic eruptions are
the most cataclysmic events ever to have
taken place
on earth and speaking of asteroids it
just so happens that
deccan traps a kinder super volcano
known as a
large igneous province erupted around 66
million years ago
right around the time a giant asteroid
smashed into the yucatan peninsula
in modern day mexico that date might
sound familiar to any budding
paleontologists out there
it's just about the time the non-avian
dinosaurs were wiped out
in the kt extinction event coincidence
well maybe exactly what part the deccan
trap super volcanic eruption had to play
in the extinction of the dinosaurs
is unclear but there is some evidence to
suggest it was these two apocalyptic
events occurring in tandem
that proved so lethal to life on earth
around 75 percent of all plants and
animals were extinguished
some scientists even believe that the
deccan trap super eruption
may even have been triggered by the
asteroid strike itself
however it went down the eruption which
was something of a slow burn
by volcano standards and may have lasted
for a million years or so
produced over half a million cubic
kilometers of lava
enough molten rock to bury england four
kilometers deep the effect super
volcanoes can have on the global climate
is also profound
the tambora eruption i mentioned earlier
wreaked havoc when it reduced global
temperatures by half a degree
but the eruption of the super volcano
beneath present-day lake toba
in indonesia the largest super volcanic
eruption of the last 25 million years no
less
caused global temperatures to fall by
between
5 and 15 degrees celsius
and triggered a period of global cooling
that endured for a millennium as you can
probably imagine
this had a catastrophic effect on life
on earth including
as it happens was we humans experienced
a genetic bottleneck around the time of
the toba eruption
during which time our entire species was
whittled down to as few
as 3 000 individuals scientists have
found
similar genetic bottlenecks in other
species too including several kinds of
primate
as well as tigers and cheetahs whilst it
may sound a little worrying that a super
volcano came so close to wiping our
species out
it should probably come as something of
a relief
after all you don't have to dig deep
through the internet to find
sensationalist articles claiming the
next eruption
of the yellowstone super volcano might
spell the end for humanity
but if our ancestors whose idea of
cutting edge technology consisted of a
sharp piece of rock
were able to survive a super eruption
it's a safe bet
modern human with our bunkers hazmat
suits
and advanced computer modelling
technology we'll be able to make it
through
a similar mini apocalypse having said
that for all our perceived mastery over
nature
if a super volcano did erupt today it
would
very likely be the most devastating
natural disaster
in human history picture the world's
least fun
game of the floor is lava okay so we've
covered some pretty big volcanoes here
but
which is the biggest of them all and i'm
not talking volcanic explosivity index
here
i mean which is the biggest volcano in
terms of height
if you'd said mauna kea in hawaii bravo
you're wrong but bravo because mauna kea
is indeed
the tallest volcano on earth at a
majestic
10 200 meters above sea level
but the biggest volcano we know about
isn't on earth at all
olympus mons the tallest volcano in the
solar system can be found
on mars at a mind-blowing 21
meters olympus mons is approximately 2.5
times the height
of mount everest it is so obscenely tall
in fact that if a commercial jet were to
take
one hell of a wrong turn and fly towards
it to cruising altitude
it would crash right into the side less
than half way up
thanks for watching thanks again to
babel for sponsoring this video
don't forget to check them out using the
link below